We built the entire library out of recycled bottles.
Fried ants are delicious.
We finished the clinic in a rainstorm.
Really?
That was a confidence builder.
My students actually ended up teaching me.
So I learned this dance. Let me show you this dance.
The classroom was more of a class tent.
You think managing a sales team is tough, try working with five different villages.
My alarm clock was a rooster.
Beans for breakfast, beans for lunch, beans for dinner. We ate a lot of beans.
I learned a third language.
My seatmate on the bus was a goat.
Always include the village elders. Always.
My morning commute was by canoe.
After two months I was ready to quit, but after two years I didn't want to leave.
I didn't know I had it in me.
Turn two years of service into a lifetime of experience.
To all the Peace Corps volunteers: past, present and future,...